how's it going relish - period so today
we're gonna play I mean nothing I'm
kidding I hate that game anyway we're
gonna make head lateral damage it's a
game about being a cat I think let's see
how to play you are a can yes good job
me
nah call your owners possessions onto
the floor oh god it's too complicated I
can't keep up with this Wow
can't wait to play this oh my god so
much best game ever done it oh wow oh
cool
this is best game can i scoop on the
carpet cuz otherwise this is not an
accurate representation of a kitty cat
so I'm supposed to flip everyone's [ __ ]
[ __ ] yes God go away
ugly it's what you get for feeding me
that [ __ ] dry food go away
oh you're okay oh cool I can jump like a
kitty [ __ ] oh hi oh you made it
good job ugly ugly ugly ugly see all
these things are ugly in my sheer
presence of a kitty kitty I need to get
up there I need to charge this [ __ ]
come on yeah I judged it wrong so this
game is just by wrecking other people's
[ __ ] fantastic you love it
ugly shoot those are all actually ugly
shoes they deserve to go what kind of
what kind of cat would put on these
whatever these are called in English I
don't know Gavi attic I don't know I
find it surprising how many people still
think I'm American like Jesus I don't
know these things
why would he have so many of these ugly
shoes God all right you can is that me
hahaha
no way I could jump this high if I would
if that was me you're ugly oh that has
to be me of course [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
fat [ __ ]
yeah no way I'm scratching in the [ __ ]
best joke I ever made
alright
and what I was saying was I used to have
a cat anyway what the [ __ ] just happened
I waited 12 kilos and it was so fat we
didn't even feed him that much I don't
understand how we got so [ __ ] fed
we've had disorder and that he could
walk oh I can penetrate whoa hey it's
like playing pool as a cat it works so
awkward
it's like I'm flexing on my penis this
is how I do it in real life
don't imagine that okay you're welcome
um anyway this story by the kid again oh
yeah we had this Dewar and they he was
so fat they would I would like come back
from from school and he would just be
stuck into it like not even trying to
move and just look at me like how it's
funny it was funnier in my head actually
I feel so awkward and yeah I am
I missed a cat not really it was an
[ __ ] all cats are [ __ ] let's be
honest here I gotta get these away how
did it's hard
Skippy's this game could be MLG Jesus
I'm so [ __ ] Oh chicks tonight sorry Oh
Jeff Lemm really let's get a [ __ ]
hardcore game man Jesus I need 20 more
books the books go go go come on come on
yeah more mess ha ha ha all right let me
let me [ __ ] your some pleases now now
now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
what you get for not opening the door I
scratch for five minutes
god it's like you don't even pay
attention don't you know who I am you
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] pity kitty kitty
why should I call PD PD
doesn't sound right oh god I'm so good
at this one Jason what do I do
differently I don't even though mole is
done MLG I'll do a 360 at cats wing told
you this game as a MLG capacity I got it
I did a kakakaka ye mean asset shut up
hello kit shut up okay poor owner Jesus
walking home to this mess this is Kenny
doesn't do [ __ ] I'm getting all the high
scores 360 hmm Oh Pasha mess did a high
five that was pretty amazing
that was probably this is probably the
best game ever this is same bedroom I'm
good
I don't understand the difference the
[ __ ] is the difference what the [ __ ]
it's the dere French what'd I say [ __ ]
don't you know who I am a [ __ ]
keep woody kitty cat it why is it so
hard for me to think of a name keys
I'm fracking cheese that's my cat
annoyed oh god I spit all over now why
do I keep doing it then that's like a
dead vampire dying from strangle of a
meatball or some [ __ ] yes I know what
that sounds like it's too complicated
man I don't know what that is combo
Keenan that probably means you have to
do tricks and stuff I think
alright watch this mmm yes I'm gonna
make a dubstep montage out of this
look at this [ __ ] alright you know much
what just happened
it's my combo that [ __ ] good I'm the
best Vicky cater it Ted is everything
okay damn I gotta clean up this mess my
will notice a goddamn [ __ ] and not my
kind of place if you know what I mean
this video is just gonna be me making
[ __ ] jokes and 69 chests and I'm the
only one happy yeah all right
I saw you dig a little bit giggle like a
schoolgirl do it do it oh this pillow
dies do it do it what a great way to end
it
oh man I can't believe I play this for
actually 12 minutes what is litter box
no time limit oh my god I can just go to
town on this [ __ ] whoa whoa I can go
wherever I won't it's a cat cat life for
us it's a cat cat life for us
kitty cat cat kit kitty cat kitty cat
cat kit kit cat kitty cat cat cat still
a better game play than call of duty so
better story then column 30 woody well
you make fun of Call of Duty bro that's
why I wish I could do more [ __ ] like
peeing the cereal or some stuff like
normal cats dude there's something
degree there's something extremely
enjoyable about this gameplay and I
really can't explain it
Oh pillow you want to come with me um
it's pretty cool actually
this game is just in alpha um hey I
guess it can add a lot of stuff to it
feels a little empty plus all these ugly
shoes I don't I don't get that
where oh [ __ ] this is probably expensive
I probably shouldn't touch just Cateye
you think i D like [ __ ] I think oh [ __ ]
either everyone keeps saying cats always
land on their feet
right I want to try that let's see if
that works
oh [ __ ] cats confirmed Illuminati yay
wow this has been life-changing for me I
hope it has been for you as well I'm
sure I mean I mean you could play you
watch me play as a cat what else would
you want from life this is probably the
high point for both of us
well yeah it's it's it's a satisfying
game I'd give him that I'd fun playing
it so if you had fun watching I check
out the game yourself I'll leave a link
in description it's it's free after all
and then I'll probably play it again if
they add a lot more stuff to it
that being said thank you boys for
watching go ahead and leave a like right
now it would help me out a lot and I'll
see you in the next episode
it's a brofist for your breasts say
awesome I don't know why I keep doing
the back ok how about this